hello everyone and welcome to a game so
many of you have requested before it
even finished uh it's uh alexander
grisham versus maxima sheila grub from
round 11 of the 2021 candidates
tournament
and it's uh quite an impressive one
again uh grisha
strikes with e4 and maksim goes for his
sicilian but
this time uh well this time it's a
little bit different so let's see what
happens here grishok with the white
pieces
opens with e4 we have c5 by maxine like
we said
going for his sicilian defense and now
knight to c3 already
a surprise uh uh on move two now opting
for the close sicilian with d6 by maxine
and now striking in the center with d4
so still opening up the position but now
the queen will recapture on d4 so c
captures queen captures
and now knight the c6 attacking the
queen and this is nothing new this has
been played
many many times bishop to b5 one of the
options
pinning that knight but queen to d2 more
more popular one
so g6 preparing to fianchetto the dark
square bishop
and b3 as the queen is in the way of the
dark square bishop you want to place it
to b2
and then continue your game we have f4
uh sorry bishop to h6 now you could
develop the bishop wow sorry about that
uh you could develop the bishop to g7
but bishop the h6 kind of forces white's
reply because if you move the queen then
bishop captures and c1 comes and it kind
of ruins white's plans
and even though in most lines of uh well
the like the sicilian the pirates
defense or
something like that where black will
find cattle the uh dark square bishop
it's in white's
interest to trade off at the dark square
bishops but here it would uh
go in black's favor so here f4 as
planned
knight to f6 now and the bishop to b2 we
have
e5 uh striking in the center right away
and now
there are 17 games in the database where
this exact same position has been
reached even in
extremely top tier games and the g3 was
the move that was played here
exclusively
but here we have knight g to e2 by
grishok and it is already as of move 9
that we have a completely new game
so let's see how maxine deals with this
he castles kingside and
sasha castle's queen side so as you can
imagine uh
or if you might uh you know uh have seen
the previous video that i've shown
uh when players cast on opposite sides
of the board uh
all hell can break loose so here bishop
to e6 continuing development and now a
nice prophylactic king to b1
you do not want your queen and king on
this diagonal while this bishop is on h6
so king to b1
uh definitely makes sense and now a5
striking on the queen side a4
uh can come at any moment and then black
might you know consider sacrificing some
material
so here a4 agriculture doesn't allow
that and now
queen to b6 a slight improvement the
queen to b6 is maybe knight to b4
uh sorry knight to g4 because it not
only does it threaten knight to f2 which
would
attack both rooks uh but also prevents
uh
white from just freely starting to
attack uh the
black black's king side so it would take
you a few moves to consolidate here and
you don't have time
with h3 like i said knight f2 and then
you're going to play queen to b6 and so
on
uh but okay here he went immediately for
queen to b6 and now
sasha doesn't have to wait he starts
attacking on the king's side so
h4 we have rook ate the c8 and
now h5 advancing that pawn all the way
we have knight captures on h5
and now g3 for the moment you don't
really gain anything with this uh
rook sacrifice i know a lot of you want
to say i want to grab this knight with
the rook but after g
captures uh you don't really have f5 or
anything there's still the queen on d2
that's the problem
so instead we have g3 playing this very
slow and
now knight to b4 kind of saying okay
this knight is never leaving this
uh c3 square otherwise rook captures on
c2 is coming
so here bishop to h3 now preparing to
grab the bishop on e6
and here well you could consider not
capturing an h3 let's say you play rook
to c3 and then after captures captures
you might consider bringing this rock
over to c8
maximum just goes bishop captures on h3
we have rook captures and
now bishop back to g7 uh another thing
you might consider is queen to f2 kind
of stifle
white's uh counter play uh on the king
side not allow this knight to move
anywhere and
like we said this knight can't move so
queen to f2 uh definitely a move to be
considered but uh like i said uh bishop
to g7 was played
and now uh sasha just uh starts pushing
his
pawns so g4 and here he asks the
question
whether or not uh mcsteam wants to grab
the f4 pawn and here in the live
coverage
uh they've shown a very interesting line
it doesn't work but it's still
interesting
uh for example if knight captures an f4
knight captures an e captures then we
can sacrifice the rook
rook captures on h7 king captures on h7
now rook to h1 with check king goes back
and queen to h2 so this is all very nice
we're threatening checkmate
uh and now uh if black makes room for
the king let's say rook to e8 now the
king can go to f8
now we simply uh win the game knight the
d5
attacking black's queen and the knight
also opening up this diagonal
and now the point is if knight captures
on the e5 we have this amazing queen to
h8
check and that's it only one move left
for black bishop captures and rook
captures on h8 will be checkmate
so while this is a very nice idea uh
after this check and queen to h2 black
can simply play f6 and you know he has
the f7 squared there's no checkmate
there's no anything here for white but
it is very interesting so
there you have it uh so instead we have
knight back to f6
although you could capture uh maxine
senses that there definitely is danger
there
so knight to f6 and now g5 uh we have
knight back to h5 here uh you could even
capture an e4
uh and then just uh you know uh i mean
that that's kind of what you were
playing for
if knight captures an e4 knight captures
on e4 then we can play rook captures on
c2
and then of course you're not going to
give up the queen but you can move the
queen queen to e1 and then the game
continues queen to c6 maybe bring the
other rook into the game
uh looks uh very interesting but again
yeah it's it's a completely crazy
position anything can happen here
but instead after this g5 move we have
knight to h5
now uh trying to dare grishok into
capturing this knight
and while you could do this again it
might be a bit too soon captures
captures and f5
uh you always have to deal with this
queen to have to move simply
paralyzing uh all of your counter play
and even if f6 you can bring the bishop
back
nothing really happening here for
example queen captures and these six
this is
this is good because if any rook attacks
it you're just going to capture it and
checkmate the black king
because the pawns are nicely covering
the e7 and g7 squares
but now uh we might do something like h4
we start pushing
pushing our past pawn and uh you know
it's still a game it's being played but
agriculture goes for something that's uh
even stronger and instead of just
grabbing here he pushes
f5 and now maxime really has to figure
out uh how to defend this position
so he starts by rook f2d8 definitely
makes sense
uh defends the d6 pawn and also uh gives
his king
a little more breeding room uh and the
situation on the clock is 28 minutes for
grishok
and 45 minutes for maxine so not that
great for grishok as it's only moved 20
but uh
is used to that and here we have f6
going after that bishop another move you
might consider is something like queen
to a1
trying to bring the queen into the
attack uh and
also bishop to a3 seems reasonable if
the knight ever moves then you can
attack this very nicely but also you can
just eliminate this knight and then you
don't no longer have to worry about this
knight attacking the c2 pawn
but there's time for that we have f6
bishop to f8
and now comes knight to g3 asking do you
want to
trade knights because then if uh
captures captures i can just shift the
rooks over to the h
file and the black might have a very
clever defense for example h5
and then if g captures an h5 alpha song
then king to h7
uh sorry on h6 uh then king to h7 and
you sort of use
white's uh own pawns as a shield uh
whether this would work or not it's hard
to say
you know it would it would be a very
very interesting game but okay
here uh uh maxime decided to counter
not with uh uh this uh sneaky idea but
rather with
d5 right away opening up the d file we
have
e capture some d5 and only now knight
captures on d3
rook captures and h5 now and now it's uh
it's very interesting but now i think
that grishok
missed a g captures on h6 because here
it's a little bit stronger
point is that now uh if if you go king
to h7 then
knight the e4 and you're just getting
destroyed here knight the g5 is coming
so it's a bit of a different line
uh and if you don't go king to h7 if you
go queen captures on f6 then again
rook to h3 you threatened to push the
pawn and if king to h794 is again
extremely strong just attacking the
queen
coming to g5 and that's pretty much it
uh queen f5 knight
check you're gonna go somewhere h7
checking a cheat rook to f3 is coming
and that's it once the queen moves night
uh knight captures and that's it
so it's a bit of a different position
than uh than uh going for this h5 idea
in the position that we've already shown
but okay here he goes queen to e2
and now rook to c5 adding another
attacker to the d5 pawn
also preparing to double up on the c
file uh
rook the h3 now preparing to sacrifice
some material here
and knight captures on d5 now we have
knight captures
rook c captures on d5 and now rook d the
h1 so what do you do here queen to d6
tripling up here on the d file preparing
rook to d1
check and here uh while you could go for
rook captures on h5 it's not
as potent because then rook to d1 check
you have to play king to a2 and then for
example g
captures you have to play something like
rook to h3
or something like that you don't really
have the option of
doing anything rook captures on h5
doesn't really do anything so here if
you go rook to h3
with the idea of capturing and
delivering checkmate then we have this
rook the a1 check this is how black goes
about this bishop captures and queen to
d1
now you either trade queens or you're
never grabbing that pawn as the queen
defends it and here after captures
captures
and captures we would have this position
uh where white is up upon it's a nice
position but uh hard to imagine you
would be able to
uh to push for a win here uh so instead
after queen to d6
grisha goes for the uh king the a to
move right away he keeps his options
open doesn't grab justin
doesn't just grab anything and now rook
to d1
and only now rook captures an h5 we have
g
captures on h5 and now grishok doesn't
repeat the line that we've shown rook to
h3 followed by rook to a1 check
instead after this g captures on h5 he
he just plays rook captures on h5
and now what do you what do you play
here problem is if you try something
like rook to d2
queen e4 and uh white wins it it's that
simple
so here instead after rook to d2 you
have to guard against queen to e4 uh we
have
rook to d4 offering the rook up for a
bishop uh but
white is not interested in giving up uh
this very strong attacker so here we
have rook
back to h1 now preparing queen to h5
queen h7 checkmate
and here a nice rook captures on a4 and
this is just a very sneaky idea because
if the rook is captured then
queen the d4 or the d5 would check picks
up the rook on h1 white's attack is over
and black just wins the game
so instead after rook captures uh
garishu just goes back king to b1
and now queen to d5 centralizing
attacking the
rook on h1 queen the h5 and now how do
you defend checkmate
there's only one move and this is what
maxime goes for queen captures on h1
very nicely done the move from the
thumbnail is on the board we have queen
captures on h1
and now rook to g4 and here we have two
rooks and a bishop against the queen and
a bishop and
this is uh well this is uh pretty much
enough to play for a draw uh with bishop
captures an e5
grabbing the e5 pawn and now rook
captures on g5
rather than capturing right away you
might consider uh
just defending this pawn or even pushing
to b5 maybe you create a pass pawn here
also an idea but this is already moved
36 and we need to reach time control so
here rook g5
queen captures on b7 a very important
pawn to grab and now
rook to d2 so here uh maxime does have a
lot of attacking potential he can use
his rooks to go after
this pawn here but the lights this light
white's dark square bishop will do a
fine job
of defending against any any checkmate
threats so here
bishop the c3 attacking the rook uh a
nice idea here would have been bishop to
f4 you don't win a rook but
for example after rook to g1 check king
b2 and now rook to e2
getting the rooks out of the way queen
to a8
is just deadly how do you defend against
uh just a double attack here you can't
move the king otherwise you lose the
bishop so
it's a very interesting idea point is
that he was probably worried about this
and he didn't have enough time to
calculate what happens here
but you will be able to run away for
example rook captures on c2 check
king to d3 uh rook c to f2
and as there is no check the bishop is
covering this square but now we just
play bishop h6 and
this is how we win material rogue g3
check king e4 and after
let's say anything there are no more
useful checks here
uh rook captures an f6 we're just gonna
capture here on f8 and now
we have more than enough material to win
the game so after rook d2 bishop f4
definitely a good move but okay bishop
the c3 was played
uh better saved than sorry and rook to
e2 now the
the rook is coming to g2 either way so
here we have queen to c8
and now comes uh rook the g1 with
check king to g2 sorry king to b2 and
only now rook g to g2 going after the c2
pawn
and this is move 40 by both white and
black we've reached time control and now
it's time to
you know relax and find all the all the
greatest moves
so here bishop captures an a5 and of
course rook
captures on c2 with check grabbing that
queen
uh you had to do this there was no other
way so
queen captures on c2 and now comes rook
captures on c2 and this was the position
that was very much
discussed and even i think chess 24 uh
tweeted about how bishop to a3 might
have
saved the game uh and the while it might
have it doesn't uh
seem that it would have because if
bishop to a3 check
of course bla white doesn't capture
after king to b1 for example
rook captures on c2 king captures and
now king f8
uh point was that after this bishop
moves you gain an additional tempo for
the black king so you can start
advancing your king here but it is not
enough
for example king to c3 king to e8 now
you're going to play bishop to b4
uh force the bishop to move otherwise
you're just up opponent a completely
winning game bishop c1
king to c4 you're gonna play king to d7
and now
king to b5 white is much much faster
uh bishop to g5 attacking the pawn here
but bishop to e7 and now after king to
e6
if you try and go after this pawn it
doesn't really work but it doesn't
matter even if you try and
defend uh we can even show for example
if you go somewhere up the board then
with the white king advances but if you
try and trade this
again it doesn't work just b4 we can
trade here
white king moves and now of course the
white pawn is much much faster
and even if you don't do this like i
said if you go king to c8
uh it's still uh just you know king to
c6 and now the pawn just advances
there's nothing
nothing you can do here uh you can never
block along this diagonal because the
bishop just blocks that bishop so
it's always in white's interested trade
and this is just winning
uh but okay uh here rook captures and c2
was played that doesn't really change
things
king captures on c2 and now king to h7
and now feel free to pause the video and
try to find
the winning plan for white while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on not playing
anything weird like
king the c1 and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show
uh it's a king to d3 not only king to d3
you could also play bishop to da try to
get bishop here you could also play
bishop to c3 a lot of
moves are interesting but king to d3 is
very much straightforward
and this is of course now winning the
only move you don't
do here is b4 b4 is just bad uh because
then you really allow king to g6 and now
it doesn't really matter what you play
because if you go bishop to d8 to defend
the pawn then you lose this pawn
and if you don't do this if you try
something like b5 advancing your past
pawn
then just king captures an f6 and it's
really no problem stopping this pawn
king e6 here and then just bishop to d6
and you don't have any any good ways of
uh well
doing anything here it's just a draw so
congratulations to everyone
that did not want to push this pawn to
b4 even though in most cases
uh pawn to b4 is a great move uh but
here it's not so here king d3
we have king to g6 and now bishop to c3
for the moment defending this pawn king
to f5 now comes king to c4 and now
king to e6 uh we have b for now starting
to advance the pawn
bishop to d6 and here uh grisha just
went
b5 and he was in this position on mu 48
that uh maxime bashir lagrav resigned to
the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so really really tough
second half of the tournament for maxim
he was leading after the first half of
the tournament
but then i guess he didn't uh really
enjoy this a whole year
break from the candidates and he can't
really catch his rhythm but it's really
different because he came as a
substitute for
temu rajabov and he really came without
much preparation but now he kind of had
a whole year to prepare so it's kind of
it's a bit of a different uh thing
because you know
if you don't perform then you always
think you could have uh
you know studied better prepared for the
tournament better but this way
when he was just a substitute for rajabo
he didn't really have a lot
of time so he just came and he he played
really really well
uh not that he's not playing well now
it's just that he's not uh you know
converting all of his for example uh
black plays with
with the sicilian he you know i believe
this is his
third loss already but yeah here we
resign uh because
uh there's just nothing you can do about
this pawn uh you could
just push this bishop back and forth but
doesn't really help king c5 you're gonna
push the bishop back into c6
bishop b8 b6 and that's just it bishop
to d6 you're going to play b7 and if
uh bishop here you're now you're just
going to play bishop to b4
yeah you don't really care about this
pawn anymore because then bishop to d6
wins
uh for example bishop a7 of course
you're not going to trade and then after
king to b5 king to e6 just kink the a6
and now you remove the bishop and then
we promote the pawn if you go here then
we capture it
and of course if you trade then we just
we're just much faster you can push f5
but then this comes with
check and that that's just it and even
if you don't do this uh for example
after bishop to b4
uh you don't have to uh you don't have
to capture the pawn you could just start
moving uh
with with the bishop uh it doesn't
really help
uh for example you could play something
like uh
or you could even yeah okay we showed
that line we you could capture the pawn
but then bishop to d6 is just
uh enough and we we we go into a pretty
similar line bishop a7 king b5
and that's it if king e6 again we play
this king to a6 move and that's it not
much to worry about king captures bishop
king captures and after f5 now again
this comes
comes with check uh
uh or rather i i think uh yeah sorry i
think that's the line that we've already
shown
we have to show what happens if you
don't capture the f6 pawn after bishop
to g3
now we play bishop to a5 and then we
threaten this so bishop has to go back
we go bishop to c7
and now after bishop to a7 now it's the
the same line sorry about that king b5
and that's it king d7 king a6 we don't
care about our bishop
captures captures and that's it next
movie we queen uh with
check so really weird uh you you guys
were probably like well what's just
happening we just saw that line yeah you
know
life is weird like that uh but yeah uh
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
really awesome stuff
for grishok and what does this mean for
the standings well we're probably going
to show one more game and then we're
going to discuss the standings but i
will just say
uh that uh anishigiri is the one that's
uh
now now has the most chances of
dethroning uh
yaniponishi from the being the leader of
the candidates tournament but he still
has um
well three very important rounds he giri
still needs to face carwana grisha
and alexenko uh to try and you know
overcome uh jan's lead but we'll see
what happens
three round is uh a lifetime in the
candidate so we'll see what happens
uh so um once again i hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
edmund freeman
vladilaro raymond david kimura and lucas
berlund for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing the coverage of the
candidates
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and do whatever else happens
in the chess world
uh thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day